Jesse Smollett hospitalized after what's
being called a racially charged possibly
homophobic hate crime et has learned
that the 35 year old actor was brutally
attacked while in Chicago on Tuesday
around 2:00 a.m. the Chicago Police
Department confirmed they received a
report of possible racially charged
assault and battery including a cast
member of the television show Empire
reports claimed to unknown offenders
approached Jesse by yelling out racial
and homophobic slurs towards him before
they started beating him in the face and
pouring an unknown chemical substance on
Jesse authorities also say at one point
one of the offender's wrapped a rope
around Jesse's neck then fled the scene
this is some really sad news to report
right now but we are thankful to hear
Jesse is doing well right now area
central detectives have an ongoing
investigation underway for battery
authorities are collecting videos
potential witnesses to get a sense of
the timeline of events now before the
attack that grape-juice net said jesse
received an odd letter that read in part
you will die using racial and homophobic
slurs we would prefer not to show Jesse
appeared to be in good spirits after
landing in Chicago on Monday taking to
Instagram with these funny updates he
poked fun about how long it took him to
get to the Windy City riding hashtag
mood after spending seven hours on a
plane for a two-hour flight
but finally landing all good
after news broke of the alleged attack
Jesse's Empire family spoke out writer
and director Eric Heywood tweeted I will
burn your house down to protect Jesse
Smollett write that down jesse has been
very open with et in the past about
being out and proud in real life and on
TV so here's what he said about his
groundbreaking work on Empire this is
the most exciting that I've been about
Jamal and his storyline probably since
season one it's it's back to doing the
things that really really matter
there's nothing frivolous about this
storyline you know it's a healthy
relationship between two men two black
men and you know I would get to deal
with the fact that ties hiv-positive the
fact that Jamal is on prep I don't think
a lot of people even know what prep is
it's incredible to be on this set and
just the amount of crew members and even
cast members that come up to me and I
feel like I did not even know about prep
I didn't know about you know how it is
with you know relationships and HIV and
it's very very real it's very real and
it's very honest and just the idea of
them getting engaged and just being
happy guys be sure to subscribe to all
things et for the latest on Jesse's
recovery and these allegations we will
be keeping tabs on that until next time
I'm at Kourtney underscore teza know bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]